[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja
Hayali schönen guten Abend und es gibt
wenn man das im Kontext eines Krieges
überhaupt sagen kann gute Nachrichten
aus Israel zwei Geiseln sollen am Abend
freigelassen worden sein das berichten
jedenfalls mehrere Medien fragen wir
direkt nach bei Michael bwerunge in Tel
Aviv Michael was weiß man bisher über
die Freilassung und die
Hintergründe ja auch als kospodent freut
man sich in diesen Zeiten mal positive
Nachrichten zu verkünden tatsächlich ist
bestätigt dass zwei israelische Frauen
freigelassen worden sind ältere Damen um
die 80 ihre Männer sind noch immer in
Gewahrsam in Gaza äh der Deal ist
offenbar über
Ägypten verhandelt worden es gibt eine
weitere Gruppe von etwa 50 Geiseln die
freigelassen werden sollen das soll über
eine andere Schiene laufen über die
Kataris äh bisher gibt es aber dazu nur
Gerüchte angeblich ist bereits das Rote
Kreuz auf dem Weg zur Grenze äh die
Kataris sollen bestätigt haben dass der
Deal sicher sei aber da gibt es noch gar
keine Bestätigung also vorherst erstmal
nur zwei Frauen die tatsächlich
freigelassen worden sind zwei Israelin
das noch wichtig weil es eine Diskussion
git ob denn nur vielleicht Israel ist
mit doppelter Staatsbürgerschaft
freigelassen würden und Israel ist nur
mit israelischer Bürgerschaft
Staatsbürgerschaft nicht das ist der
momentane Stand am Freitag waren ja
bereits schon zwei Geiseln freigelassen
worden die Hamas tut das ja nicht
wirklich freiwillig was bekommt die
Terrorgruppe
dafür also von offizieller Seite heute
die verlautbachung der Armee nichts man
habe nichts dafür als Gegenleistung
gegeben bisher ist es dann erstm nur ein
wenn man so will merkwürdiger Public
Relations Erfolg den quasi Entführer
Verbrecher haben wenn sie ihre Geiseln
freigeben und sich damit vielleicht als
humanitär den Anschein geben im
Hintergrund gibt es natürlich einen
Zusammenhang mit den humanitären
Lieferungen die Israel ja zulassen muss
und teilweise auch verhindert hat und
inwi weit das jetzt tatsächlich genauere
Zusagen gibt für weitere hilslieferungen
das ist nicht bekannt aber auf jeden
Fall gibt es da einen Zusammenhang
Michael die Bodenoffensive ist ja bisher
noch nicht gestartet weil einige
darunter eben auch die USA sich so mehr
Zeit erhoffen um noch mehr Geiseln frei
zu bekommen heute ist das gelungen gibt
es eigentlich auch eine gesichtsbahene
Möglichkeit für Israel sie gar nicht zu
starten
das glaube ich nicht in Umfragen sagen
fast zwei Drittel der Israelis dass sie
für diese Bodenoffensive sind und eine
Umfrage von heute sagt auch dass über
70% einen Sieg voraussehen
und eigentlich ist für die Israelis klar
es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten man macht
diese Bodenoffensive und man zerschlägt
die Hamas oder man Verzicht auf die
Bodenoffensive dann kann man die Hamas
aber auch nicht zerschlagen also ich
glaube nicht dass grundsätzlich äh
sowohl die Führung als auch die Armee
Abstand von dieser Bodenoffensive
genommen haben es ist nur eine
Verzögerung die offensichtlich eben auch
mit den Verhandlungen um die Geiseln
zusammenhängt sagt Michael bwerunger
auch heute für uns live aus tellav
vielen Dank und damit blicken wir jetzt
nach Gaza das Leid dort geht weiter das
Sterben geht weiter die Angriffe gehen
weiter aber die Bodenoffensive ist wir
haben es gerade gehört noch nicht
gestartet auch weil in Israel weiter
darum gerungen wird was Priorität
Geiseln befreien oder die Hamas
vollständig zerstören wie es ein
Brigadegeneral heute erneut formulierte
und während Israel weiter über die aus
seiner Sicht richtige Strategie
nachdenkt geht es für die
Zivilbevölkerung im Gazastreifen mit und
ohne Beschuss ums Überleben es fehlt an
fast allem insbesondere an Treibstoff
Tim
Krüger auch heute Rollen Lastwagen über
den Grenzübergang Rafa zwischen Ägypten
und dem Streifen beladen mit Hilfsgütern
wie bereits am
Wochenende es ist vor allem
Krankenhausbedarf Medikamente sind dabei
und Nahrungsmittel wir verteilen das mit
dem palästinensischen roten
Halen das aber reiche bei weiten noch
nicht aus so die Vereinten Nationen die
UN fordern größere Lieferungen vor allem
fehle es auch an Treibstoff um die
Generatoren für die Kliniken zu
betreiben und noch immer ist unklar wann
eine mögliche Bodenoffensive der
israelischen Armee im Gazastreifen
beginnen könnte diese Soldaten und
Reservisten trainieren bereits für den
Häuserkampf in der vergangenen Nacht
wurden laut israelischer Armee bereits
vereinzeln Bodenoperationen in Gaza
durchgeführt in der Nacht gab es
Angriffe von Panzer und
Infanterieeinheiten bei diesen Angriffen
werden trups von Terroristen getötet die
sich auf die nächste Phase des Krieges
vorbereiten diesri tief bis zur
kontaktlinie bei diesen ren werden auch
Informationen über die vermissten und
die Geiseln gesucht und
gefunden noch aber gehen vor allem die
gegenseitigen Angriffe mit Raketen
weiter die hammas feuerte heute in
Richtung Israel die israelische Armee
flog in den vergangenen 24 Stunden laut
eigenen Angaben 320 Angriffe dabei soll
es laut Behörden in Gaza viele Tote und
Verletzte gegeben haben
hier im Süden sein wir sicher hieß es
jetzt haben wir hier in hanjunes so
heftige Angriffe wie nie laut der
israelischen Streitkräfte habe man
ausschließlicher massziele angegriffen
Satellitenaufnahmen sollen
abschussanlagen zeigen die sich neben
zivilen Einrichtungen wie einem
Kindergarten Schulen einem ungebäude und
einer Moschee
befinden am Abend dann die erleichternde
Nachricht dass die beiden älteren Frauen
und der ham freigelassen wurden in Tel
Aviv werden sie wohl dennoch weiter
jeden Tag demonstrieren dass noch mehr
Geiseln
freikommen meines Erachtens sollte die
Planung einer Bodenoffensive nicht an
erster Stelle stehen Obste Priorität
sollte sein die Kinder und Frauen nach
Hause zu bringen und zwar
jetzt noch immer sind es mehr als 200
200 Schicksale und dahinter die Angst
das Bangen der Verwandten und
Freunde ja also weitere Geiseln befreien
Zivilisten und die Menschenrechte
schützen Flächenbrand verhindern es sei
die Quadratur des Kreises die Diplomaten
gerade im Krieg in Israel betreiben
müssen das sagte Außenministerin
annaalena berbock heute am Rande des EU
außenministertreffens in Luxemburg das
Ulf Röller für uns beobachtet hat Ulf
guten Abend nach Brüssel wie kompliziert
das mit der Quadratur ist das haben die
euaußenminister heute im Grunde bewiesen
sie konnten oder wollten sich nicht auf
einen Waffenstillstand aus humanitären
Gründen einigen warum
nicht also ganz einfach gesagt weil sie
doch sehr zerstritten sind Europa hat
keine einheitliche abgestimmte
naroststategie keine Politik die
einheitlich ist und das ist ein großes
Problem gerade jetzt wo die Krise so
groß ist man kann das sehr vereinfacht
sagen es gibt zwei Lager da gibt es
einmal die Palästinenser versteher das
sind Länder wie Spanien Portugal und
Belgien und die betonen sehr sehr stark
bei jedem Auftritt immer wieder den
Schutz der Zivilbevölkerung und die
dramatische Lage im Gazastreifen und sie
sagen dass das Recht von Israel auf
Selbstverteidigung eben seine Grenzen
hätte und dass das auch deutlich gemacht
werden müsste und sie fordern lautstärk
einen Waffenstillstand und dann gibt's
die andere Gruppe ich nenne sie jetzt
mal die israelversteher angeführt von
Deutschland die sagen es bringt
überhaupt nichts lautstarke Vorschläge
den Israelis zu machen das ist Seer
kontraproduktiv das würde als
Provokation wahgenommen und natürlich
sagt Deutschland auch sehr deutlich in
dieser Gruppe das Recht von Israel auf
Selbstverteidigung ist eben absolut das
Haupt Anliegen und man kann Israel keine
Vorschrift machen und diese beiden
Positionen sind mehr oder weniger nicht
miteinander vereinbar und so kommt es
dass Europa eben keine einheitliche
Politik hat in dieser sehr sehr
schwierigen Frage age und das führt dazu
dass Europas Einfluss in der Region
wahrscheinlich abnimmt die
Einschätzungen von Ulf Röller zum EU
aßenminister treffen heute vielen
herzlichen Dank
dafür ja die Welt blickt auf den Krieg
in Israel aber auch der in der Ukraine
geht ja weiter eine Konsequenz aus der
russischen Invasion will schon seit
längerem Schweden ziehen das Land hatte
die Mitgliedschaft in der NATO beantragt
und nach monatelanger ade der Türkei
Gundel kommt da tatsächlich Bewegung
rein der türkische Präsident erdogan hat
das beitrittsprotokoll unterzeichnet und
dem Parlament zugeleitet Ankara hatte
den natobeitritt Schwedens bislang
blockiert mit dem Vorwurf Schweden gehe
unzureichend gegen Terrororganisationen
wie die kurdische Arbeiterpartei PKK vor
die Zustimmung in Ankara gilt nun als
wahrscheinlich es fehlt noch die
Ungarns auf dem Militärflughafen Köln
waren Proben Bundeswehrsoldaten und
zivile Einsatzkräfte die Zusammenarbeit
für den Fall dass Deutschland Truppen an
die NATO Ostflanke verlegen sollte
Bundeskanzler Scholz erklärte es sei gut
zu sehen dass in kurzer Zeit
funktionierende Strukturen aufgebaut
worden sein es gehe dabei auch darum die
richtigen Schlüsse aus der Zeitenwende
des russischen Angriffskrieges auf die
Ukraine zu
ziehen über die Lage im Süd Kaukasus
berät Russlands Außenminister lavrov in
Teheran mit seinen Amtskollegen aus
Armenien und Aserbaidschan der Iran
hatte eingeladen um gemeinsam auch mit
der Türkei ein Abkommen für den
Südkaukasus zu erarbeiten das unter
anderem russische Interessen
berücksichtigt Aserbaidschan hatte im
September das Gebiet Bergkarabach
erobert und 120.000 Armenier in die
Flucht
getrieben vor dem Oberlandesgericht
Düsseldorf hat ein halbes Jahr nach
mutmaßlich islamistisch motivierten
messerangriffen in Duisburg der Prozess
begonnen dem 27-Jährigen Angeklagten
wird Mord und dreifacher Mordversuch
vorgeworfen der syer sei Anhänger des is
und habe so die Bundesanwaltschaft mit
den messerangriffen in einem
Fitnessstudio und auf offener Straße
wahllos vermeintlich Ungläubige töten
wollen eines der Opfer war seinen
Verletzungen
erlegen macht sie es oder macht sie es
nicht und ja sie macht es nach
monatelangem Hin und Her hat Sarah
Wagenknecht heute verkündet dass sie aus
der linken austreten und eine eigene
Partei gründen wird die Aufmerksamkeit
war ihr wie immer eigentlich wenn Sarah
Wagenknecht irgendwo Auftritt auch heute
sicher sie ist nun mal eine Person die
für viele eine ja gewisse
Anziehungskraft hat das sieht man auch
daran dass laut einer aktuellen Umfrage
von heute das Bündnis von ihr aus dem
Stand auf 12% käme ohne dass man das
Programm oder das Personal kennen würde
Andrea Maurer über den Schritt
wagenknechts und die damit verbundenen
Konsequenzen für links bis rechts
außen den Vorhang zu ihrer parteig
Gründung hat Sarah Wagenknecht mit einem
Paukenschlag gehoben nur kurz zuvor ist
sie mit neun anderen Abgeordneten aus
der Linkspartei ausgetreten um dann vor
versammelter bundespresse das Bündnis
Sarah Wagenknecht vorzustellen erst
Verein ab Januar Partei gegen die Partei
der sie 30 Jahre angehörte gegen die
ampelregierung gegen einen sogenannten
Mainstream wagenkncht ist Name Gesicht
Programm wir haben uns zur Gründung
einer neuen Partei entschieden weil wir
überzeugt sind so wie es derzeit läuft
darf es nicht weitergehen denn sonst
werden wir unser Land in 10 Jahren
wahrscheinlich nicht wieder erkennen
Wagenknecht verlässt die Linke nicht
ohne einen letzten unfreundlichen Akt
trotz Parteiaustritt haben sie und ihre
Leute den Antrag gestellt vorerst in der
Linken Bundestagsfraktion zu bleiben für
einen geordneten Übergang wie es heißt
wir haben ein Antrag gestellt auf
Verbleib in der Fraktion und dann müsste
eine Mehrheit der fraktionsversammlung
der Auffassung sein dass diesem Antrag
nicht entsprochen wird die Linksfraktion
deren Ende die Austritte besiegeln wäre
also gezwungen noch einmal
fürwagenknecht zu stimmen damit
Mitarbeiter nicht sofort arbeitslos
werden klar ist der linke Rand des
Parlaments wird sich verändern der
rechte Rand muss wohl zittern
Wagenknecht könnte der AFD Stimmen
abjagen der AFD Chef wiegelt ab ich habe
mir die Pressekonferenz auch angeschaut
von den Inhalten her muss ich sagen habe
ich mich ein bisschen gewundert es ist
fast eins zu ein AFD also Verein für
Vernunft und Gerechtigkeit so heißt
jetzt erstmal es gibt eine Partei für
gesunden Menschenverstand das ist die
AFD also von daher ist es ein weiterer
politischer Mitbewerber aber ich habe
jetzt keine angstperlen auf der Stirn
und soziale Gerechtigkeit der Verein
soll jetzt Spenden sammeln politische
Unterstützer antreten wird die Partei
zur Europawahl antreten will sie bei den
ostdeutschen Landtagswahlen in Thüringen
etwa was eine Gegenkandidatur zum linken
Ministerpräsidenten
wäre wenn sie wirklich ein Zeichen gegen
die AFD und Herrn höcke setzen will
könnte sie ja gemeinsam mit mir
kandidieren ich bedauere dass sie diese
Idee nicht aufgegriffen hat und dass sie
jetzt auf einmal einen ganz anderen Weg
geht die Linke Parteispitze hat
Wagenknecht aufgefordert ihr Mandat
niederzulegen die drei Direktkandidaten
Lösch pmann und gizi schließen sich an
von menschlicher Enttäuschung ist die
Rede Gesi hat bis zuletzt versucht
Wagenknecht
aufzuhalten ich glaube nicht dass diese
neue Partei 2025 in den Bundestag
einzieht sie will Flüchtlingspolitik wie
die AFD machen Wirtschaftspolitik
wie Ludwig Erhard und Sozialpolitik ein
bisschen wie die Linke und dann hat man
immer die Hoffnung man kriegt von allen
drei Wählerinnen und Wähler da kann man
sich aber auch täuschen das kann eine
minusrechnung werden es ist die erste
bundesdeutsche Partei die sich allein
mit einer Person im Zentrum Gründen wird
Protestpartei linksonservativ
populistisch sie wird wohl die
Parteienlandschaft auf absehbare Zeit
verändern erster Verein dann die Partei
aber im Grunde dreht sich dann doch
alles um Sarah Wagenknecht und damit
einen schönen guten Abend nach Berlin
guten Abend Frau Wagenknecht die Linke
und sie sie gehen jetzt also auch
offiziell getrennte Wege warum geben sie
nicht auch ihre Mandate ab das wäre doch
konsequent also ich denke das wofür ich
stehe das haben ja viele Menschen auch
gewählt als sie die Linke gewählt haben
und ich erinnere mich als im im Juni der
Parteivorstand mich aufgeforordt hat
mein Mandat zurückzugeben das wurde ja
damals schon beschlossen haben mir ganz
viele Menschen geschrieben war nicht
wenn sie ihr Mandat zurückgeben dann
möchte ich auch meine Stimme zurück weil
ich habe die Linke nicht zuletzt wegen
ihnen gewählt insoweit es ist natürlich
immer ein bitterer Prozess wenn es zu
einem Punkt kommt an dem wir jetzt
stehen aber ich finde wir sollten jetzt
diese Trennung auch mit Anstand machen
und ja uns da nicht mit Reck bewerfen
also ich bin jetzt wirklich ganz
motiviert auf das neue Projekt mich zu
orientieren und das andere ist
Vergangenheit also ein Prozess der ja
auch etwas länger gedauert hat jetzt
haben sie heute wirklich die
Entscheidung getroffen Wähler könnte man
sagen entscheiden natürlich auch und
zwar bei der nächsten Wahl aber das auch
das ist ja ihre Entscheidung ob sie die
Mandate behalten oder nicht der Linken
Chef nennt ihr Vorgehen allerdings
völlig unverantwortlich weil sie das
Nachrücken anderer eben verhindern und
somit die Fraktion zerlegen ist ihnen
die Linke mittlerweile so egal nein die
Linke ist mir nicht egal aber wir müssen
einfach sehen die Linke ist leider eine
Partei geworden die politisch von den
Wählern immer mehr abgestraft wurde also
sie war ja mal eine Kraft die auch in
unserem Land etwas bewegt hat Ich habe
mich über viele Jahre in der Linken
engagiert aber durch die Veränderung sie
ist nicht mehr die Partei die sie damals
war die Parteiführung hat ein anderes
Konzept und für dieses Konzept gibt es
ganz offenkundig nur noch ein sehr sehr
kleines Wählerpotenzial und das ist der
Hauptgrund warum Menschen in der Linken
begonnen haben auch schon vor mir und
unabhängig von mir darüber nachzudenken
ob es nicht eine neue Kraft braucht und
es geht ja gar nicht primär um die Linke
sondern ich finde wir haben in
Deutschland einfach ein ganz große
repräsentationslücke viele Menschen
wissen nicht mehr was sie wählen sollen
wir leben in einer Zeit massiver
geopolitischer weltpolitischer Krisen
und wir haben gleichzeitig die
schlechteste Regierung die die
Bundesrepublik jemals hatte und es muss
sich einfach etwas verändern sonst sehe
ich wirklich sehr schwarz für die
Zukunft weil wir haben die Gefahr dass
Deutschland wirtschaftlich absteigt und
das möchte ich gerne verändern es sind
natürlich komplexe Herausforderungen
viele Kriege und Krisen da darauf
antworten einfache vor allen Dingen zu
finden das ist eben unmöglich thürings
AFD Chef höcke der hatte ihn ja Anfang
des Jahres angeboten bei der AFD
mitzumachen sicher auch weil damals wie
heute viele AFD Wähler Sie eventuell
wählen würden aktuell wo laut einer
Umfrage zwischen 30 und 40% trifft das
ihr politisches Spektrum also kämpfen
sie um das gleiche
Klientel also ich denke es täte den
Debatten in Deutschland gut wenn wir
mehr über vernünftige Politik und
weniger über die AFD diskutieren würden
und natürlich gibt es ganz viele
Menschen die wählen die AFD nicht weil
sie recht sind sondern weil sie wütend
sind weil sie verzweifelt sind weil sie
das ist ja auch ein Grund warum wir an
den Staat gegangen sind wir haben ganz
viele gesagt wir wissen nicht mehr was
wir wählen sollen in den vorhandenen
Parteien ist für uns nichts wir sind zu
tiefst wütend darüber wie schlecht
dieses Land regiert wird wie falsch die
Prioritäten sind die die Ampel setzt sie
die Menschen haben das Gefühl es muss
sich was ändern und viele haben daraus
den Schluss gezogen okay wenn jetzt
erstmal nichts anderes da ist wählen wir
AFD wir wollen diesen Menschen ein
seriöses Angebot geben wir woll aber fr
nicht nicht wenn ich sie da ganz kurz
unterbrechen darf es ist ja so dass
Menschen sie jetzt eventuell wählen
würden obwohl sie weder Programm noch
Personal kennen also heißt das nicht es
geht gar nicht mehr so sehr um Inhalte
und
Überzeugung ja wir haben ja heute mit
dem St des Vereins auch ein Programm
vorgelegt natürlich ist das noch nicht
30 Seiten lang sondern das sind vier
wesentliche Punkte aber diese vier
Punkte dafür stehen wir das ist einmal
eine Politik eine Wirtschaftspolitik
eine Energiepolitik die vernünftig ist
die die industrielle Wertschöpfung hier
in Deutschland erhält die einen starken
Mittelstand erhält der zweite große
Punkt soziale Gerechtigkeit meine
Deutschland ist in den letzten Jahren
immer weiter auseinander gedriftet die
Politik hat von den fleißigen zu den
oberen 10.000 umverteilt wir brauchen
gute Löhne ein ordentliches Rentensystem
das ist in manchen westeuropäischen
Ländern deutlich besser geregelt und
unsere drittes großes anlegen wir
brauchen eine Außenpolitik die sich
wieder an den Traditionen der
Entspannungspolitik orientiert also auf
Diplomatie setzt Deutschland hat lange
Zeit ist sehr gut damit gefahren auf
Vermittlung auf Ausgleich zu setzen und
nicht auf militärische Lösungen und
viele kon Politik sie haben das
friedliche Außenpolitik genannt sie
haben sich ja heute bei der
Pressekonferenz dann auch zum Krieg in
Israel geäußert da haben sie gesagt der
Staat hätte selbstverständlich das Recht
sich gegen die Angriffe der terrormiliz
Hamas zu verteidigen zudem sagten sie
aber auch dass Gaza seit vielen Jahren
ein freiluftgefängnis sei machen Sie
denn dafür nur wenn man bei ihrem
wording auch bleibt nur Israel oder
vielleicht auch Ägypten und vor allen
Dingen die Terrorgruppe Hamas
verantwortlich ja natürlich gibt es
viele Verantwortliche meine Botschaft
war ja nur auch dieser Konflikt wird
sich nicht mit Waffen und mit
militärischen Mitteln lösen lassen und
ich sehe mit großer Sorge eine
bevorstehende Bodenoffensive weil ich
denke dass das ganz ganz viele
Zivilisten das Leben kosten wird und es
kann den ganzen Nahen Osten zu einem
Pulverfass machen also auch dieser
Konflikt muss diplomatisch gelöst werden
und der wird auch nicht gelöst werden
können ohne dass die Interessen auch der
Palästinenser berücksichtigt werden ja
sie sprachen dann auch von einer zwei
staatenlösung die ja viele befürworten
auch deutsche Politiker z.B auch der
bundespr Präsident und andere aber wie
soll das jetzt gehen verhandeln mit der
Terrorgruppe Hamas oder mit wem nein
also mit der Hamas muss man nicht
verhandeln die es gibt ja durchaus
andere Repräsentanten der Palästinenser
ich glaube nur dass es wirklich wichtig
wäre dass die israelische Regierung die
ja aktuell die zwei staatenlösung
ablehnt hier andere Signale setzt damit
es einen Frieden gibt damit es eine
friedliche Lösung gibt weil die
Vorstellung dass dieser Konflikt einfach
bleibt und man das wegmoderiert das kann
nicht funktionieren und natürlich haben
die PAL
auch ein Recht auf ihre Interessen und
dass die Situation in Gaza so nicht
bleiben kann das ist ja tatsächlich der
Fall ja sagt Sarah Wagenknecht
insbesondere sind heute glaube ich
erstmal auch viele gespannt wie es mit
ihrem Bündnis weitergeht sie streben
jedenfalls anbeit allen drei
landtagswahen im nächsten Jahr im
Ostenland dabei zu sein inklusive
Thüringen wo die Linke den
Ministerpräsidenten stellt Frau
Wagenknecht vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit
sehr
gerne und das Gespräch haben wir am
frühen Abend aufgezeichnet jetzt geht es
bei dir gunduller auch mit einer Frau
weiter die im Grunde andere neue Wege
bestreitet mit Christiane Benner steht
zum ersten Mal in der über 130-jährigen
Geschichte der IG Metall eine Frau an
der Spitze der Gewerkschaft erneut hat
sie von der Bundesregierung Änderungen
der Industriepolitik gefordert Frank
betmann welche Hauptziele hat sie sich
dabei gesetzt na ja sie übernimmt das
Kommando ja in schwerer Zeit die
Autoindustrie die Stahlindustrie der
Maschinenbau die Branchen in denen die
IGI Metall stark ist stehen vor großen
Veränderung allein durch den Abschied
vom Verbrennungsmotor drohen tausende
von Jobs wegzufallen die neue Chefin
Benner will diesen Umbau aktiv
mitgestalten zu einer
Deindustrialisierung dürfe es nicht
kommen zeigte sie sich heute beim
Gewerkschaftstag hier in Frankfurt
kämpferisch unsere Industrie in
Deutschland muss weiterentwickelt werden
und nicht abgewickelt Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
Benner setzte heute weitere Duftmarken
ein klares Jahr zu einem von der
Regierung subventionierten
industriestrompreis und auch klare Kante
bei der Rente mit 63 sie sei eine große
sozialpolitische Errungenschaft so die
55-Jährige ja die 2,2 Millionen IG
metallmitglieder haben eben auch ihre
Erwartungen klar keine Frage auch die
größte Einzelgewerkschaft der Welt
verliert Mitglieder muss also schauen
was sie den Beschäftigten bieten kann
mit der Forderung nach einer 32 Stunden
Woche mit entgeldausgleich will Benner
in die nächste Tarifrunde gehen das
Kalkül dahinter klar Industriearbeit
auch für junge Menschen und Frauen die
noch in Teilzeit arbeiten attraktiver
machen Frank betetmann vielen
Dank deutsche Unternehmen kommen immer
schlechter an neue Bankkredite lauto
Institut berichtet fast jeder dritte
Betrieb von höheren kredithürden die
Banken erhöhten die Kreditzinsen und
seien bei der Vergabe zurückhaltender
besonders betroffen sein Dienstleister
wie die
Veranstaltungsbranche das Baugewerbe und
der
Einzelhandel bei einem symbolischen
Spatenstich für die Stromtrasse anord in
Meppen hat Bundeswirtschaftsminister
habbeck erneut schnellere
Entscheidungsprozesse bei der
Energiewende gefordert die 300 km lange
Trasse soll in einigen Jahren offshor
stromon von der Nordsee ins Rheinland
leiten der Baubeginn erfolgte jetzt rund
ein halbes Jahr früher als geplant aber
so habeg Kritik die Leitungen kämen fünf
bis se Jahre zu
spät ein Bestseller nach dem anderen
bereits über 20 Millionen verkaufte
Bücher in 37 Sprachen übersetzt das ist
Cornelia Funker einfach eine
herausragende Autorin allerdings ragt
sie aus ihrem privaten Domizil einem Hof
in der to
nicht ganz so gerne heraus nicht weil
sie etwa menschenscheu ist sie kümmert
sich dort beispielsweise um kreative aus
der ganzen Welt sondern eher weil sie
Medienrummel nicht unbedingt braucht im
Grunde bräuchte sie auch keine große PR
rund um ihr neues Buch das wird sich so
oder so verkaufen aber für den vierten
Teil der tintenweltreihe die Farbe der
Rache war sie dann doch auf der
Frankfurter Buchmesse unterwegs Susanne
bcker über eine Frau mit dem besonderen
Blick für unsere Zeit und ihre darin
liegenden
Geschichten eine mittelalterliche Stadt
Italien Sehnsucht Bücher die lebendig
werden cornelia Funkes tintenweltreihe
zieht seit 20 Jahren Fans in aller Welt
magisch an und das neue tintenabenteuer
nimmt den geheimnisvollen Feuerzauberer
Staubfinger in den Blick ich habe ja
irgendwann meinen Mann damit überrascht
dass ich gesagt habe ich begreife immer
me Staubfinger wahrscheinlich sehr wie
du es da sind bestimmte Züger die mich
immer wieder an meinen Mann erinnern
obwohl das nicht die Absicht war ihr
Mann Ralf ist vor 17 Jahren
gestorben in ihrem Anwesen in der
Toscana gründete Cornelia Funke eine
Stiftung für artists in resid oder
sistisch auch wiedergeben könnte Heaven
barim kam mit ihrer Familie 2015 aus
Aleppo über das Mittelmeer nach
Deutschland ich wollte ein Buch über
unsere Geschichte schreiben über den
syrischen Krieg und die Flucht nach
Deutschland und Cornelie hat mir auch
viele Tipps und mich sehr unterstützt
und sie ist an meiner
Seite Cornelia Funke hat über 60 Bücher
geschrieben mehr als 31 Millionen Bücher
verkauft in mehr als 50 Sprachen
übersetzt ihre neue Tintenwelt Saga wird
ihre Fans überraschen als ich dann die
ersten drei enttenbücher noch mal hörte
dachte das ist sehr finster ich glaube
ich muss ein bisschen me Hoffnung in
diesem Buch fühber machen nach den
Jahren die wir alle hinter uns haben und
nach den schweren Zeiten in denen wir
sind schulde ich meinen Lesern auch das
Bewusstsein dass ich auch das Prinzip
Hoffnung vorkommen lassen muss und
vielleicht ist das der allerwichtigste
Aufgabe des
Geschichtenerzählers Trost zuen und so
begegnen wir in der neuen tintensaga die
Farbe der Rache irgendwann auch jungen
Heldinnen voller Mut mit großer
Naturverbundenheit und starker
Freundschaft eine von ihnen heißt heavin
wie die junge Frau aus Aleppo und das
verdanke ich vielleicht auch all den
Jungen die ich hier immer wieder erlebe
und meinem großen Respekt für diese
Generationen und das war eigentlich die
schönste Überraschung während des Buches
so ein bisschen zu merken Cornelia du
glaubst ja eigentlich dass die Jungen
die Welt retten
werdenel ganz es herrschte Frieden in
ombra seit mehr als 5 Jahren
doch an dieser kühlen septembernacht
gedachte die Stadt al derer die für
diesen Frieden gestorben war und wie
jedes Jahr gab ihnen ein Mann durch die
Flammen eine
Gestalt
Feuertänzer Staubfinger hörte wie die
Menge den Namen den Sie ihm gegeben
hatte voll Dankbarkeit
[Musik]
murmelte Frieden Hoffnung Trost schön
schön W es ja und bitter
nötig um 23:50 Uhr meldet sich Laura
barnick mit unserem heute journal Update
das war's von uns beiden machen sie es
gut wo auch immer sie sind tschüss bis
[Musik]
morgen guten Abend laut der US
Wetterbehörde Noah wird zu 99% dieses
Jahr das global wärmste seit
Aufzeichnungsbeginn auch das Wasser die
Orange Linie zeigt
2023 ist wärmer denn je Klimaerwärmung
und beginnendes elnin Phänomen im
Pazifik reichen als Erklärung kaum der
Ausbruch des unterseeischen Vulkans
hunga Tonga im Januar
2022 hat sehr viel Wasserdampf in die
Stratosphäre gebracht anders als normale
vulkanusbrüche deren schwefelpartikel
das Klima kühlen könnte das wärmen der
Nordatlantik vor Europa ist so besonders
warm weil das Azorenhoch an seinem
angestandten Platz dieses Jahr nur
selten zu finden war Folge schwache
Passatwinde Flaute über dem Meer erhöht
dessen Oberflächentemperatur es
verdunstet weniger und kälteres
Tiefenwasser bleibt in Ruhe
unten außerordentlich warm ist aber
nicht nur der Atlantik sondern z.B auch
das Mittel mehr aktuell mit 23 bis
27° so sind auch unsere
Nachttemperaturen recht mild sie sinken
heute auf 12 bis 5° über die Westhälfte
breitet sich Regen aus der wird morgen
Vormittag bereits die Küsten erreichen
ganz im Osten zeigt sich anfänglich noch
die Sonne dann kommt neuer Regen
hinterher der nordostwt zieht und zum
Nachmittag könnte dann westlich des
Rheins schon wieder die Sonne
hervorkommen der Wind kommt aus
südlichen Richtungen so bleibt es auch
morgen mild bei uns bei 11 bis 17° und
windig regnerisch und mild geht's in den
nächsten Tagen weiter guten
Abend